Joe Biden's message to illegal
immigrants during his campaign was let
them come I'd have the tape but I said I
wouldn't play the tape and since taking
office Biden said he's gotten control of
the Border vice president kamla Harris
uh Homeland Security secretary May orcus
uh Biden's press secretary Karine je
Pierre have all said the border is
either secure or the border is closed
yet the border patrol says well guess
what they have been a record 6.5 million
in count with illegal immigrants and
so-called Asylum Seekers at the border
since President Biden took office the
administration says well they don't know
how many people actually are in the
country illegally gentlemen the American
people I ask you um I believe it's your
turn Governor Nome have the American
people on the issue of borders you're
defending the Biden Administration
they're saying the border secure they're
saying the borders closed those are the
numbers from our own border patrol are
the American people being lied to I
don't think they're being lied to the
Biden Administration put out a
comprehensive plan day one when he got
sworn into office three years ago and
the Republican Party didn't touch it
they haven't moved on it they play
politics with us and I'll be honest with
you I think there's probably one person
I wouldn't listen to on this topic more
than the guy that I'm standing next to
Ronda santis he is absolutely lacks any
credibility on the issue of immigration
when he was in Congress he supported
amnesty when he's in Congress you
supported John Boehner's Bill to
when you were in Congress you
supported you supported Obama's efforts
to advance comprehensive reform the last
guy you want to talk to on the isue
immigration your immigration policy can
best be described as a governor from the
state of Florida going into another
state the state of Texas lying to
migrants promising them jobs and housing
sending them to an island Martha's
Vineyard and then sending him to a
parking lot in Sacramento California
California I met with those migrants
that you lied to under false pretense
that kind of
gamesmanship using human beings as ponds
I think is disqualifying so again a guy
who stands here who's been out on the
Republican debate stage saying well he's
going to be tough he's going to shoot
people with backpacks uh and that he has
a strategy to potentially even invade
our second largest trading partner uh
Mexico that has a record of supporting
amnesty and supporting reforms under the
Obama Administration is the last guys to
be standing on stage talking about the
issue of immigration reform tonight well
I'll tell you what it's deja vu all over
again with that flurry of Lies this is a
guy that says the Biden Administration
is not lying to the public about the
Border they go to the white house uh
briefing room every day they say the
border is secure they are lying to you
we know that that's not true Gavin Nome
is lying to you when he says somehow I
supported these things which I didn't do
he's also lying to you uh about what
it's going to take to solve this problem
California is a sanctuary State uh they
thumb their nose at Federal immigration
law and this has real consequences uh
there was an illegal alien Herbert Nixon
Flores uh who was in LA uh in custody
was a repeat criminal ice wanted to take
him into custody because then they would
be able to deport him La refuses to work
with ice and so they wouldn't turn him
over they end up releasing him on the
street he ends up murdering the mother
of a three-year-old little girl uh that
those policies are deadly uh they do not
work and I'll tell you this uh the
Martha Vineyard transport Martha
Vineyard said it was a sanctuary
jurisdiction kind of reminds me about
Gavin Nome when he restricted
Californians then he went to the French
Laundry these liberal Elites they like
to impose burdens on you they don't want
to have to face the consequences of
their action so we've got a lot of
Elites who want open borders who lecture
everybody else about it then the minute
they have to deal with any of the
consequences oh man all hell breaks
loose
get we'd be much on the same topic on
the on the same topic this is important
this is a very important question while
some migrants I know want to come to
America for a better life for themselves
and their family find the American dream
I I totally sympathize with them uh many
good people fling very bad situations
abroad um but others are abusing the
Asylum process and in the process in
search of of where they're coming from
we're now learning that many are coming
from some of our top geopolitical foes
countries with little to no vetting or
people that are coming in they're not
being vetted look at these numbers
between October 2021 October 2023 border
agents encountered
6,386 Nationals from Afghanistan
3,153 from Egypt
659 from Iran the number one state
sponsor of Terror 538 from Syria
12,605 from Russia and a whopping
26,136 our enemies are going to take
advantage of this he opened the Border
he's not uh VI he's violating his oath
of office to take care that the laws are
Faithfully executed he's knowingly
having 8 million come in and yes there's
criminal aliens there are terrorists
there's a lot of fentol that we've had
tens of thousands of fentanyl deaths
I've had the uh uh I've met a lot of
Angel parents who have lost kids to
fentanyl overdose and and the problem is
you you'll have a a a college kid that
may take some pill not knowing that
there's fentol in it and then right
there that can be fatal they're
poisoning our people and Joe Biden is
sitting on his hands he refuses to take
care of the Border he refuses to hold
the drug cartels accountable this is the
vision of Biden Harris Nome open borders
Americans suffer and Americans continue
to die because of fence and over us
there will be unfortunately a terrorist
attack at some point that we'll be able
to trace back to our Southern God forbid
by the way do you see that risk govern
new govern do you see do you see the
risk Joe Biden put out not only a
comprehensive plan he consistently puts
up plans hold on is there risk I'm going
I'm going to answer your question I I
support border security I think the
Asylum system is broken I believe that
we need I'm the one that I'm the only
guy here that's a border state Governor
you're trolling folks and trying to find
migrants to play political games try to
get some news and attention so you can
out Trump trump and by the way how's
that going for you Ron you're down 41
points in your own home State on the
issue of immigration Joe Biden put a $14
billion immigration package up in front
of Congress 2300 border agents as well
as custom officials 1,000 new law
enforcement officers to deal with a
fentanyl issue and by the way that's a
major issue in your state 41% higher
overdose rates than the state of
California and here's what I haven't
heard not a peep from Ronda santis they
want to demagogue this issue you want to
play politics with issues you don't want
to solve this issue why don't you leave
and support
thaton hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere
else